après les confessions de françois
hollande aux journalistes du monde
c'est au tour de ségolène royal
d'exprimer des doutes quant au projet
d'aéroport de notre dame des landes
face au blocage du site elle s'oppose
une nouvelle fois au premier ministre il
vaut mieux arrêter les frais la justice
a tranché
et donc quand il y a les propos comme
cela on ne revient pas sur la parole du
kremlin
je ne sais pas mais on ne revient pas et
on ne joue pas avec la démocratie
il souffre aux as avec méthode et
personne ne peut mettre en doute
non seulement l'autorité du premier
ministre les l'autorité des électeurs
pourraient être un nouvel exemple lors
je veux pas eu des gros mots mais de ce
que devenu ce gouvernement c'est à dire
un gigantesque foutoir même claude
bartolone le président de l'assemblée
déclare dans cet article qui se pose des
questions je cite et sous couvert
d'anonymat un autre parle de suicide
politique
on vous imagine pas comme ça finalement
cessé surprenante vous entendre on a vu
d'agiter comme quelqu'un qui n'ait
jamais dit de robots depuis qu'il est né
comme quelques scènes vraiment je suis
un homme comme les autres comme vous ça
vous arrive de jurer aussi bon si ça
m'arrive de jeu rétorque je viens à
florange dire que j'ai respecté
l'ensemble de mes engagements
la phrase du jour est signée françois
hollande le président de la république
donne ce matin une interview dans
plusieurs quotidiens locaux
j'ai toujours tenu bon il ne faut jamais
se laisser emporter par tel ou tel bout
de phrase sortie de son contexte voilà
ce que dit françois hollande prend les
hauts fourneaux ne tourne plus ne fume
plus n'existe plus là-bas et la
reconversion est en marche oui d'accord
mais bon s'ils voulaient je pense pas
qu'on puisse remplacer l'industrie
française
d'ailleurs florange étaient un site
rentable
le président de la république a l'air de
faire un peu la tournée des popotes pour
faire le bilan de ce qu'il aurait promis
pour dire si si vous n'êtes pas bien
compris mais j'ai approché balcon et
d'ailleurs c'est en toute discrétion que
françois hollande arrive sur le site
d'arcelormittal
il est attendu par la direction et
quelques salariés une visite sous
contrôle pour éviter toute image gênante
le rouge c'est le symbole de ce qui a pu
être
premier qui était tenue avant si vous
voulez y avait 3000 300 cdi à 5 ans qui
se lever le matin qui naîtra il
sollicite aujourd'hui sont 2300 ça c'est
factuel
ce qui est en cause c'est le dénigrement
rituel c'est le fatalisme c'est
l'abandon
c'est la résignation arcade avait
observé avec beaucoup de tension entre
les six personnes qui étaient autour de
moi
deuxièmement un déficit de politique et
un surcroît ou une surabondance de
gestion et d'administration par quand je
vois que dans cette ambiance totalement
glacée ou l'électro encéphalogramme
était totalement plat c'est pour les
commentateurs jean frédéric poisson qui
a gagné le débat on se dit que justement
quand un cap là le moindre friselis
ressemble à un tremblement de terre
interroge plusieurs personnes qui me
disent on va voter jean frédéric poisson
ça vous fait quoi
c'est une d'abord c'est une très bonne
idée et je veux dire à tous les
manifestations que le 20 novembre le
poisson est à 2 euros qu'on en profite